So there are some signals
that exist in the record books.
Right?
And to some, that
means the aliens have
already tried to contact us.
In 1977, the Ohio
State University
had a big radio telescope.
It's been turned, I think,
into a golf course now.
But one morning, one of the
astronomers, a guy by the name
of Jerry Ehman,
he comes in and he
looks at the last
night's observing, which
is all printed out on paper.
That's the way
computers used to work.
Paper.
And he's going through
these papers-- remember paper?
And he finds this big signal.
And he writes with
a magic marker,
he writes wow next to it.
So that's become known
as the wow signal.
Now, the big question
was could this
have been the aliens trying
to get in touch with Ohio?
And the answer is, we
don't know the answer
because that instrument
automatically looked again
70 seconds later, a little
over a minute later,
and didn't find the signal.
People have continued
to look for it.
We've been looking for it.
And we haven't found it either.
So what do you
conclude from that?
It could be that
the aliens broadcast
once and then went on vacation.
It could be.
But you would never
call that science.
If you don't find
it another time--
We can't repeat it.
So that's one.
And how about the
Kepler object that had
this weird eclipsing material
in orbit around the host star?
Yes, KIC 8462852.
It kind of rolls off the tongue.
Is that his phone number?
We'll check it out later.
Anyhow, this is a star
that's quite far away actually.
It's almost 1,500
light years away.
That's pretty far
for most stars.
And it is seen-- Kepler measured
its brightness over the course
of years really.
And you know, stars don't change
their brightness very much.
But this one suddenly
dipped in brightness
by more than a fifth, 22%.
Very unusual.
The sun never does that.
Thank goodness.
OK?
It wasn't because there was a
planet going in front of it.
That would never
dim it that much.
So the question is, what was it?
And one suggestion, made maybe
semi-seriously, was well,
maybe there's a
civilization there,
and they built some
astro-engineering project which
is blocking some of the light.
And they're taking
that energy and feeding
their planet with it.
For example.
They could be doing that
so-called Dyson sphere.
Yeah, OK, so now, just
keep it in the list here,
a few months ago, Russians
made an announcement
of a radio signal that could
represent intelligent life.
Indeed, the
Russians back in 2015
had used a big antenna
down close to the Caucasus.
It's called the RATAN-600.
It's from the Soviet era.
It has big women turning
cranks and stuff like that.
But it's a big antenna.
And they found a signal
coming from the star
HD 164595, another
wonderfully named star.
That star is known
to have planets.
And they thought,
maybe this is it.
But they didn't make
any noise about it.
They didn't tell people.
And that's a strong indication
that they themselves thought
it might be interference.
But somebody wrote
a blog about this.
And so for a week, the media
went nuts about this star.
We tried to check
out the signal.
The Berkeley people tried
to check out the signal.
No signal.
The Russians were forced
to announce, look, we think
it was a military satellite.